Es wird immer klarer dass die erde einem wahren asteroiden bombardements ausgesetzt ich
Ständig schwirren um uns ziemlich großer brocken herum sie kommen masse nichts und sind mega gefährlich der solid der gerade an uns vorbei
Gerast ist hatte die sprengkraft von mehreren dutzend atombomben wäre ja eingeschlagen hätte
er locker eine großstadt
Vernichten können danke an stefan burger aus der web community die das thema vorgeschlagen hat also herzlich willkommen bei klick zum science fiction
Ja schon zahlreiche asteroiden ein schläger haben mir auf der erde für riesige katastrophe gesorgt und das scheint keine
Erscheinung der vergangenheit zu sein wir werden wohl ständig bombardiert
Und es gibt auch ständig ein schläger auf der erde ohne dass wir es bemerken dieser 50 meter ass
zählt also ein ziemlicher brocken kamen der erde gefährlich nahe
200.000 kilometer das ist die halbe entfernung zwischen erde und mond und in kosmischen maßstäben
Nichts fast ein treffer und und das ist erschreckend, er wurde erst 21 stunden vorher überhaupt entdeckt vorher schwirrte
jeffrey
Unerkannt durch unser sonnensystem und es werden immer mehr von diesen erdnahen asteroiden entdeckt wenn sie entdeckt werden
Im jahr 2000 kannten wir nur 1000. Jetzt sind es schon knapp
20.000 die die umlaufbahn der erde
Kreuzen und bekannt sind und jedes jahr werden eben mehr entdeckt asteroiden sind ein überbleibsel von der entstehung unseres sonnensystems
Die meisten von ihnen ziehen glücklicherweise weit entfernt von der erde ihre runden. Um die sonne zwischen den planeten mars und jupiter
Das wachstum der entdeckung der erdnahen asteroiden ist übrigens ex potenziell und das finde
Ich wirklich alarmierend ich hatte ja schon öfter hier darüber berichtet und es ist ja einer meiner lieblingsthemen wir
unterschätzen die gefahr solcher asteoriden
2018 sie
Zwar um einiges größer als der asteroid der im februar
2013 über russland explodiert war die explosion des termins hatte damals lediglich eine druckwelle
ausgelöst sie beschädigte mehrere tausend gebäude und für rund 100 menschen
ein einschlag hätte dagegen die stadt komplett zerstört verglichen mit der hiroshima bombe hatte
Er die 20 bis 40 fache sprengkraft entsprechend tnt war es die von
600 kilo tonnen
2018 die tri hätte also viel schlimmere auswirkungen gab die erde ist ständig bedroht von kollisionen mit
Erdgas 7 viele objekte sind klein und verglühen in der atmosphäre ohne dass wir es bemerken dass ein himmelskörper
In die atmosphäre eindringen und explodiert oder anschlägen kommt allerdings öfter vor als wir denken
Wie oft das in den letzten 13 jahren passiert es wurde ja erst kürzlich
bekannt werden darüber berichtet 26 asteroiden sind auf der erde eingeschlagen darauf kommen
Sind bekommen findige wissenschaftler sie hatten die idee beim weltweiten atomteststopp
Überwachungs netzwerk nachzufragen ob es andere größere explosionen auf der erde gab als atombombenexplosion es waren
26 lediglich ein einschlag wurde dabei vorher gesehen alle anderen kamen. Im wahrsten sinne des wortes
Aus heiterem himmel wie jetzt 2018 sie ist für jedes jahr schlagen also zwei
Größere asteroiden hier auf der erde ein bisher hatten wir großes glück denn die gesteinsbrocken schlugen. Im meer wüsten oder sonstigen
unbewohnten gebieten ein jetzt haben die usa
Ja die neue behörde planetary die fans koordination gegründet sie soll erdgas
Soliden entdecken und verfolgen die nasa hat jetzt das ziel bis 2020 alle erdnahen asteroiden die größer sind als
140 meter zu entdecken nach immerhin schon etwas denn genau diese
Könnten der erde sehr gefährlich werden und mehr als nur eine statt vernichten experten plädieren deshalb immer wieder für eine bessere weltweite zusammenarbeit
und den aufbau eines koordinierten
frühwarnsystems wirklich effektive
abwehrstrategien sind neumann nicht ausgetüftelt wir hätten in diesem fall einen anschlag nicht verhindern können deshalb hat die nasa zusammen
Mit dem kernwaffen dabei lawrence livermore national laboratories
Jetzt das projekt hama gestartet hemmer steht für high velocity edition
Mission for emergency response auf deutsch über geschwindigkeit asteroiden entschärfung mission für notfallmaßnahmen es geht wirklich zum ersten
Mal darum die kuban eines asteroiden gezielt zu beeinflussen
das wäre eine
wahnsinnig wichtige zivilisations leistung ohne die wir auf dauer wahrscheinlich nicht überleben würden
Wenn er als erstes neues zum thema hast du ihn einschläge und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert und zur begrüßung gibt es noch ein kleines geschenk
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht was aber mit der
Immer mit der glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dabei auch darauf liegt az rast auf die erde
Zu nasa plant bombardierungen da gibt es mehr zu diesem thema was die nasa davor hat ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran